do you would you would you date would
you would you see a woman as less value
if
for example if they have a like a
history of maybe dating the wrong man
yeah because I think I think women
struggle with this so much because as a
man obviously you can you can confirm to
me as well when you're young and you're
like 16 you got no money you got no
chest you've just you're just you've not
barely hit puberty and the 19 year old
swells up in his little Ford Focus and
grabs your babes and you're told that
bro bro when you get a bit older you can
have a girl like this but for now you
have to deal with what you have to you
have to build yourself up boys don't get
upset with me they're like you know
Israel is the older drug dealer he had
more money took my girl is what is but
when you say to a woman
that in reverse that your value is
decreasing it's almost like they can't
fathom it like it's an exception to the
rule and it's think of a
it's not that hard to grasp that
when you get older you're just going to
get less attention to think that in your
40s you can get the same caliber of man
that you could at 23. it's not really
that hard to grasp it's like we try to
use nicer words to to say it to say I
think they see it as like attack on the
value of them yeah it's not attacking a
value of them you gotta remember the
sexual Marketplace the dating
Marketplace is like any Capital markets
any form of capitalism the best product
marketed in the best way always gets the
best outcome so the best product in this
case
would be your body marking it might be
what you wear social media the filters
you use and then that's what you're
going to go into attract the most
interest when you're in your 40s 50s no
matter how much you Market a dead
product when the breast ain't breasted
and it's sagging and you can do keep
your puppies with the breast like well
it's not the same product I'm sorry and
we have to remember I'm sorry men and
women are different men and women are
different they look at things different
we go through life different everything
is different the way you go through life
is completely different the way I go
through life do you understand so it's
like men will look at your path
to see if you qualify for my future
women are looking at a man's future
do you understand like you want to know
that yeah this guy can provide for any
future offerings of offsprings that we
might have this guy can provide for me
you can give me security that's all
future based a man will look at your
past do you understand like who have you
who have you dated like was your hoe
like you know have you been ran through
Jonathan these are all past stuff and
just to see if you qualify for his
future and if you if you obviously in
your past you know you did things in
your past that makes you disqualified
then that's just how the cookie combos
is because remember if you've worked all
this time to attain this and you've made
all the best choices that's why you see
a lot of older man in terms of forget
Beauty from the side a lot of older men
will wife younger women and I'm not
saying [ __ ] stupid ages I'm saying
like 30 to 23 just for the reason of
less
less chance of baggage she's like why
would I grab a 30 year old that if maybe
she's still she's still single she's
been had all these all these boyfriends
that have affected her she might have a
kid when I can just grab someone who's
23 and not have to deal with that that's
not to say he might not meet someone
who's hurt you hasn't gone through all
their things and could be amazing but
it's just a way of chances she's like
why go with the stress and headache just
like a lot of women when they pick they
might have an ex-road man who's now
going straight or they can go for the
Investment Bank it's like you know what
this guy doesn't have a History of
Violence why am I going to bother with
Jerome the road man who's now [ __ ]
some Forex guy that sells stuff on
Instagram when I can just get a solid
investment banker he's just revised his
whole life it's just a way of odds it
just makes sense do you think that
investment banker wouldn't choose then
that obviously her full dating oh well
that kind of goes back to the start
question of should well start assess it
in two parts should he date her and will
she still find him attractive because 10
years ago she thought the bad boys were
attractive so first of all in terms of
the attraction it all comes back to what
I'm saying about alphanus alphanus is a
situation and that's what makes you
Alpha so a lot of people say ma'am will
say I'm an alpha but you're not your
Alpha in this situation you're putting
so to give you an example and this is a
bit of a fact example at roller tomasi
uses is that a lot of you see that that
trend of when a teacher will
lack
leave his wife for like a young 18 year
old woman
and who used his teacher and they say he
groomed her which he did he did he did
groomer but in that situation the reason
why he managed to unlock her is because
he controls the classroom everyone looks
up to him he's the teacher he might be a
dweeb in life but he's the alpha in that
classroom and that's the way she's got
to know him so that's how he's unlocked
her brain now you when you see
eventually when she awakens is when she
leaves the classroom is run off with him
and realize he's just dweeb and no one
respected him he hasn't got money and no
one values him you see what the
difference between going or going with
Mr roadman or for the Americans for Mr
Hood guy he's a bad man then and
everyone respects him in the hood at
that age but then when you get to your
30s it's the guys with the money it's
the highest value status guy no matter
how old you get those mad values don't
diminish from 30 year old from 30 years
old if you're a millionaire you're a
boss for life you're bossing the old
person's arm you're smoking all the old
ladies you know what I'm saying you're
just a boss anywhere so that's why I
think it's a thing of the attraction
will still stay there it's not a problem
but whether you want to then go deal
with a woman that's got the baggage of a
bad guy is a different thing yeah well
and guys know like who they were in high
school so like if a guy was a dweeb in
high school and now he's worked for 10
years to get to a certain status and
then this girl says oh I used to date
bad boys all the time or like I had this
toxic ax or this this guy did this or
this guy that says taking no
accountability always painting herself
as the victim like one men can see
through [ __ ] because it takes two to
tango and two they also realize that you
would have passed on them
yeah like if they yeah go ahead yeah I I
agree with what you're saying like it in
terms of you know if a woman does go in
like and
is toxic and has a toxic situation she
could definitely carry that through to
her next relationship but
then it's like
that healing has to take place and that
person's got to find peace with their
past and I still think that
well you can find peace but like the
world is Harsh and the dating play like
the dating Marketplace is Harsh so just
because you've personally found peace
and moved on from that it doesn't mean
that the world's going to give you
understanding so I think maybe let's say
for example you know how we said like
for a woman for a man to kind of accept
a woman she has to kind of tick 80 of
these boxes whereas for women it's 100
right remember that was that was that
yeah yeah well we yeah okay close yeah
just keep going yeah
so it's like okay so if a if a woman is
able to show that who she is as a person
is meets that standard of the guy then
maybe that the baggage part of it well
yeah but like we we deal in
probabilities not possibilities so like
that's that's again illustrating my
point a little bit when I say like women
are children because even now you're
thinking of like the possibilities not
the probabilities and it comes to how
the male and female mind is is different
a lot of men fall in or women fall in
love of what like you could be and
that's why you see a lot of women will
try to fix a guy whereas a man will fall
in love with the idea that she won't
change so we meet the 23 year old Baddie
and he doesn't want her to change and
he'll just base it on all of her past
experiences to the point I've met her
now
she's had this kind of pause she's 23
she's sexy and this is how it's going to
be whereas women will fall in love with
the future so that's why the way you're
talking is it's like oh but they can be
they can be they can be that's not how
men think they just think I've looked at
this that's what it is all the mateys
from the football team have run through
her this is long I can't be bothered and
what if she like I'm just out of
curiosity like what if she didn't tell
you and
it was like and you you've got and you
fell in love with her let's say to speak
and you find out
she dated by bad men back in the day uh
depending on the guy depending on the
guy that you know
personally I the guys that I know don't
leave
yeah
because love is a choice you have to
remember that love is a choice you
choose who you love you understand
because you're looking at from a female
point of view because from a female it's
like if we fall in love like well I'll
Overlook the 10 red flags but from a
male point of view they're like cost
benefits in in a man's eyes anyway love
is a choice I chose to love you do you
understand because you showed me like
you showed me you know
you showed me things that I felt like
was valuable so I'm choosing to love you
I'm choosing to you I'm choosing to give
you
um these my my resource basically you
understand if I now found out that you
know yours on only fans or you you've
been ran through like you know you've
basically deceived me so you're so
you're going to so let's just put it
into an example right so you're going to
disregard everything that she is as a as
a person that you're feeling in that
moment that experience that you've had
with her and then you'll just be like oh
yeah well because now I know that you've
had a past
that changes my current experience
that's like okay that's like selling a
car for new prices and then later he
finds out the car has a bunch of issues
and he brings it back to the shop yeah
that's the equivalent it's like again
this is what men value they they value
youth they value Purity and they value
they value loyalty and being hot I'll
give you an example
um I was talking to one girl one time
and this was like years ago and
we she checked everything like we we had
it all good it was going well
um and one of my boys came up to me and
said yo like is she I heard one of the
guys in his friendship group had said
that she had been unfaithful and at that
moment I just went no I'm out you just
feel disgusted it was it was literally
like that it wasn't even a case if I
wanted to know I had a conversation with
her but I didn't even tell her what
actually happened and I said look I
don't think this is going to work out
um how long was you dating her Force say
three four months
but Pearl in in the UK we call it crb or
DBS checks
I don't know what you call them in the
US but it's basically like it's like a
it's like a play on words what what you
do a criminal background check so you
just say to the man them like oh
put the feeler out I like this girl like
what do you know about it she's from
here ask the man from over there and
then sometimes you get bad reports here
just like
could have been so much it could have
been so much man
but there are sometimes cases where guys
don't want you to leave the pack and
they'll they will say stuff about the
girl
but that's why you have to and that's
what you have to say to the man them
like you have to say like what's the
Intel Source because some guys will say
oh she's a slag because she slept with
two guys but that might just be two guys
from the same area they're from like
what'd you expect I think when you come
with age as well it's almost like when
someone says like oh she's been run
through that all right she's had a
one-night stand like common bro like
grow up like [ __ ] happens in it it's
more like we do talk of run through uh
he went to that meeting and then she was
in a room and then she was getting the
car keyed and then just like [ __ ] you
know